[Applause]
oh
Taylor Swift is totally bugging no
literally she accidentally swallowed a
bug during her sold-out show in Chicago
really yes how'd I do that it all went
down on Sunday on the latest leg of her
era's tour at Soldier Field
is there any chance that you know that
you saw that I think you have to keep
people's attention by surprising them
Well turns out a lot of people saw it
but Taylor totally followed her own
advice and hey baby
it's fine it's old it's I'm swallowed
okay
so I'm just gonna try not to do as many
of those this is going to happen again
tonight and while Taylor's show on
Sunday had a bug or two
the Grammy winner pulled off a Flawless
surprise on Saturday bringing out Marin
Morris to sing you all over me we are so
lucky
[Applause]
because not only did that artist say yes
maren Morris is actually here
[Applause]
she's one of my favorite artists I just
cannot wait to watch everything she does
everything she does is
so brilliant and all that love is mutual
yeah I'm not gonna not gonna seem
ambivalent about that at all Marin
shared a clip from the performance to
tick tock thanking Taylor in the caption
your generosity to me in these last
seven years is insurmountable and I love
you so
[Music]
and according to Taylor her era's tour
is all about the love
[Music]
on Friday the singer delivered a
powerful message to kick off pride month
telling her lgbtq plus fans they're safe
at her show this is a celebratory space
for you
terrible seats and then try to restore
the peace and control your urges to
scream about all the people you hate
cause shade never made anybody less gay
[Music]